alors on va faire une interview à venir
vous êtes prêts oui alors boutros
boutros ghali vous me voyez ou dans cinq
secondes toujours dit si dans cinq
minutes
toujours ici dans cinq heures quand la
maison à la maison en train de prendre
une pilule pouvoir dormir
ah oui vous êtes à trois les somnifères
tellement voyagé en avion elle tellement
de changements
oui pendant que longtemps que si vous
êtes déglingué donc dans cinq heures
déterré maison pour prendre un somnifère
koala pasqua qui se passe dans le monde
quoi qu'il se passe dans le monde parce
que le lendemain matin on à douala
occupe une solide ça quand on sait qu'en
les deux tours elle fournit pour un
somnifère dans la m dans cinq jours dans
cinq jours
je me plais pas pour partir au caire
dans cinq mois dans cinq ou moi nous
nous je me trouverai je crois ici au
mois d'août
j'espère terminer un ouvrage encore
encore
n'arrêtez pas dans cinq ans dans cinq
ans à ce moment je dois vous dire
publiquement j'avais 87 ans j'essaie
d'éviter d'être gâteux sait tout sur un
poteau dans cinq siècles dans ce rallye
à l'ancienne résurrection si jamais il
ya une seconde vie j'espère pouvoir
revenir votre os boutros boutros ghali
j'ajouterai un troisième but à sa
troisième mouture groupe préféré toc toc
à à duran duran d'autre à [ __ ]
trop c'est trop